à une vie entière passée à courageusement se remettre de sa blessure.
Il est vraiment mon héros.
Mais bien que -- (Applaudissements) oui, il le mérite --
(Applaudissements)
Mais bien que cette tragédie ait été un cauchemar pour ma famille,
je pense souvent à comment cela aurait pu être pire ;
à quel point cela est pire chaque jour pour les 90 familles
qui n'ont pas eu autant de chance,
qui ont perdu des êtres aimés -- frères, sœurs, fils, filles, parents.
Ils ne font pas tous la une des journaux nationaux.
Pas la majorité d'entre eux.
Ils passent inaperçus,
dans une nation qui a accepté cette honteuse épidémie nationale
comme la nouvelle normalité.
J'ai quitté mon travail dans la publicité
pour essayer de faire quelque chose contre ça,
car j'ai réalisé
que les défis pour empêcher la violence armée
sont les mêmes que ceux qui m'ont fait aimer la publicité :
essayer de découvrir comment atteindre les gens.
Mais, au lieu de le faire pour vendre des produits,
on le fait pour sauver des vies.
Cela revient à trouver un terrain commun
où ce que je veux rejoint ce que vous voulez.
Vous serez peut-être surpris d'apprendre l'étendue du terrain commun
en termes de violence armée.
Prenons l'exemple des personnes qui aiment chasser,
un sport apprécié pas des millions de personnes aux États-Unis,
C'est une fière tradition familiale.
Dans certains endroits,
le premier jour de la saison de chasse est un jour férié.
Que veulent les chasseurs ?
Ils veulent chasser. Ils adorent leurs armes.
Ils croient profondément
au droit du second amendement de posséder ces armes.
Cela ne signifie pas qu'il n'y a pas de terrain commun.
En fait, il est vaste,
en commençant par l'idée fondamentale
de garder ces armes hors de mains dangereuses.
Il n'est pas question d'ôter certaines armes à tout le monde,
mais de garder toutes les armes hors de portée de certaines personnes,
des personnes qui, de l'avis général, ne devraient pas avoir d'armes :
les criminels violents, les agresseurs domestiques,
les personnes dangereusement malades mentalement.
Nous apprécions tous
l'incroyable efficacité des vérifications d'antécédents de Brady
pour garder ces armes hors des mains dangereuses.
En 20 ans, ces vérifications chez les vendeurs d'armes licenciés
ont empêché la vente de 2,4 millions d'armes
à ces personnes qui, de l'avis général, ne devraient pas avoir d'armes.
(Applaudissements)
Que vous aimiez ou détestiez les armes, vous appréciez sûrement le fait
qu'il ne devrait pas y avoir des milliers de ventes d'armes chaque jour
dans les expositions ou en ligne
sans ces vérifications d'antécédents,
comme il ne devrait pas avoir deux lignes pour monter dans un avion :
une avec et une sans sécurité.
Et --
(Applaudissements)
Les chiffres montrent l'accord général parmi les Américains :
90% des Américains
sont en faveur de l'extension des vérifications d'antécédents
à toutes les ventes d'armes -- y compris 90% des Républicains,
plus de 80% des possesseurs d'armes,
plus de 70% des membres du NRA.
Ce n'est pas une idée qui fait polémique.
En fait, seuls 6% des Américains ne sont pas d'accord.
C'est environ le même pourcentage d'Américains
qui croient que l'alunissage était bidon.
(Rires)
C'est également le pourcentage qui croit que le gouvernement
met des technologies de contrôle d'esprit dans les signaux de télévision.
Nous sommes à ce point d'accord sur les vérifications d'antécédents.
Qu'en est-il des 300 millions d'armes
déjà dans des maisons dans tous les États-Unis ?
Il est important de réaliser
que ces armes sont majoritairement dans les mains et les maisons
de personnes décentes et honnêtes, comme vous et moi,
qui veulent ce que nous voulons tous -- dont la sécurité de nos familles.
C'est pour cela que de plus en plus de personnes possèdent des armes.
Il y a 10 ans, 42% des Américains
croyaient -- à tort -- qu'une arme rendait votre maison plus sure.
Aujourd'hui, ce sont 63% qui le croient.
Pourquoi ?
Je déteste le dire,
car c'est le côté sombre de la publicité
qui est qu'en répétant assez un mensonge assez gros,
ce mensonge devient réalité.
C'est exactement ce qu'il s'est passé.
Le lobby des armes a dépensé des milliards de dollars
à empêcher le CDC
d'effectuer des recherches sur l'épidémie de violence armée
relevant de la santé publique ;
empêchant les pédiatres de parler aux parents
des dangers d'avoir une arme chez soi ;
bloquant des technologies d'armes intelligentes
qui empêcheraient les enfants de tirer avec l'arme des parents
et sauveraient des vies.
Ils veulent désespérément cacher la vérité
car ils voient la vérité comme une menace sur leur activité.
Et chaque jour,
il y a des morts.
Et beaucoup sont des enfants.
Et chaque jour aux États-Unis,
9 enfants se font tirer dessus involontairement.
900 enfants et adolescents se suicident chaque année.
Et c'est presque toujours avec l'arme de leurs parents.
Même deux tiers des fusillades dans les écoles
impliquent une arme prise à la maison,
incluant la terrible tragédie
à Sandy Hook.
Je rencontre beaucoup de ces parents ;
c'est la partie la plus poignante de mon travail.
Ce ne sont pas de mauvaises personnes.
Ils vivent juste avec les conséquences inimaginables d'une mauvaise décision,
basée sur de mauvaises informations
qui leur ont été données par de mauvaises personnes,
qui ont conscience du malheur qu'elles causent
mais ne s'en soucient pas.
Le résultat est un cauchemar --
pas seulement pour les familles comme la mienne,
mais, finalement, pour nous tous.
Je ne suis pas ici pour parler du cauchemar de la violence armée.
Je suis ici pour parler du rêve que nous partageons tous,
qui est d'avoir un futur meilleur et plus sûr.
Pour mon organisation, pour la campagne Brady,
ce rêve se reflète dans l'objectif ambitieux
de réduire de moitié les morts par armes à feu
aux États-Unis, d'ici à 2025.
J'espère vous donner ce soir
le sentiment que ce rêve est atteignable.
Parce que,
pour chaque grand mouvement dans le monde,
il y a un moment où vous regardez en arrière et dites :
« Les choses ont commencé à changer à ce moment-là. »
Je suis ici pour dire
que pour le mouvement qui mettra fin à la violence armée en Amérique,
ce moment, c'est maintenant.
(Applaudissements)
Nous sommes clairement à un moment déterminant,
car les Américains se sont réunis par millions,
comme jamais auparavant, sur ce terrain commun
pour dire : « Assez ».
Assez de fusillades de masse dans les centres commerciaux, les cinémas,
les églises et les écoles.
Assez de la terreur quotidienne de la violence armée
dans les maisons et les rues
qui prennent la vie de jeunes femmes et hommes noirs
dans des proportions stupéfiantes.
Assez de l'accès facile aux armes
pour les personnes qui, de l'avis général, ne devraient pas en avoir.
Et assez des petits groupes de politiciens lâches
qui mettent les intérêts du lobby des armes
devant ceux des personnes qui les ont élus.
Assez.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui est très excitant, c'est que ce ne sont plus toujours les mêmes
qui disent cela.
C'est tellement plus de monde.
Si vous voulez une preuve,
commençons par le sujet de conversation préféré des Américaines :
Kim Kardashian.
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas vraiment une blague.
Pensez aux changements suite à des problèmes :
ils passent de problèmes politiques
à une partie intégrante de la culture pop,
des voix venant de partout, des célébrités sur les réseaux sociaux,
des musiciens, des athlètes.
La NBA a abordé le sujet.
Des commentateurs conservateurs dont vous n'auriez jamais cru cela
en ont parlé.
Il y a un vrai changement culturel --
il y aurait même un TED Talk à ce sujet.
C'est l'étendue du changement culturel qui se produit.
Et oui, Kim Kardashian a appelé, avec passion,
ses 35 millions de followers sur Twitter
à étendre les vérifications d'antécédents.
Regardons la campagne présidentielle.
C'était un sujet de seconde zone pour les démocrates.
Il fallait absolument l'éviter.
Maintenant, les candidats l'exploitent.
Certains sont obligés de revoir les mauvaises positions
qu'ils défendaient très confortablement jusqu'à très récemment.
Pour quelqu'un comme moi,
regarder les gens balancer leur évaluation très négative de la NRA --
c'est presque irréel.
Le lobby des armes a toujours plus d'argent que nous, oui,
et cela va devoir changer.
Mais vous savez quoi ?
Nous sommes plus intelligents et excités et avons la vérité pour nous.
Nous sommes à l'attaque.
On dit qu'internet démocratise l'information.
Les média sociaux et certains des outils d'organisation qui y sont liés
ont démocratisé l'activisme.
Ils nous ont permis de montrer ce à quoi ressemble 90% de soutien.
Parfois j'y pense --
nous convergeons et attaquons instantanément et par millions,
comme les globules blancs.
Ils nous ont permis de diminuer -- et c'est le point fondamental --
diminuer cette déconnexion honteuse
entre ce que veulent les Américains
et ce que nos élus font.
Jusqu'à récemment,
ce qu'il se passait au Congrès c'est que ces avis opposés,
ces 6%,
prenaient le pas sur notre parti à 10 contre 1.
Nous changeons cela.
Après la récente tragédie de San Bernardino,
nous avons inondé le Congrès d'appels.
Nous avons passé 15 000 appels au Congrès en l'espace de 24h.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Nous avons eu le vote d'une loi
que personne ne pensait voir dans un futur proche.
Nous sommes témoins d'un vrai mouvement pour repousser l'une des lois
les plus mauvaises passées en 10 ans par le lobby des armes.
Le lobby des armes est en train de perdre son emprise.
Le président Obama a pris des mesures historiques.
Elles ne sont pas suffisantes,
mais elles vont sauver des vies
car elles étendent les vérifications d'antécédents
à des milliers de ventes d'armes où elles ne s'appliquaient pas.
A travers le pays, nous marchons -- nous ne faisons pas qu'attendre
que le Congrès agisse ; cela serait de la folie.
A travers le pays, nous marchons,
État par État, comme le droit au mariage pour tous.
Vous savez quoi ? Nous gagnons.
Le Congrès est presque toujours le dernier à se réveiller et à réaliser
qu'il est du mauvais côté de l'histoire.
Et quand c'est le cas, c'est toujours parce que les Américains le secouent.
C'est exactement ce que nous faisons,
nous sommes à ce moment-clé.
Récemment, je traversais le pays pour donner un discours
face à un public comme celui-ci, bien que moins intimidant,
et la femme assise à côté de moi dévorait
une des mes séries préférées : Mad Men,
une série sur la publicité
dans les années 60.
J'essayais de penser à la façon de clôturer mes remarques,
de temps en temps, je jetais un œil à son écran,
et à chaque fois,
je voyais quelqu'un fumer dans un bureau, ou à côté d'un enfant,
ou enceinte, ou quelqu'un qui conduisait après avoir bu,
ou conduisait sans ceinture, ou harcelait sexuellement une collègue.
Et j'ai fini par réaliser :
quelle formidable inspiration
pour ceux d'entre nous qui ont ce rêve de mettre un terme à la violence armée.
Pensez à combien le monde a changé
en un laps de temps relativement court,
comment ces comportements autrefois considérés normaux --
voire glamour ou sexy --
sont devenus stigmatisés en une ou deux générations,
quand ils sont devenus des conversations sur notre terrain commun.
C'est la magnitude de changement que nous pouvons créer
autour de la violence armée.
Et c'est mon rêve,
qu'un jour peut-être,
une série télé dépeindra l'horrible cauchemar de la violence armée,
et qu'une future génération d'enfants ne pourra qu'imaginer
l'horreur que cela a dû être.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)